luxury fashion is fickle even in the
best of times
but the pandemic has taken a huge toll
on the industry
this year i had two focuses in terms of
industries
i looked at fashion and i looked at
defense and i feel like those two
industries had different reactions to
covet
in so many ways we've seen a lot of
networks and a lot of companies be
impacted by it seeing fashion in certain
cases struggled
more than other industries was very
interesting if you had a billion dollar
business last year in fashion
you're just not gonna have that this
year
at the beginning of the lockdowns in the
united states tory burch was
a little bit in the news in the way that
she was in touch with the trump
administration
to get some relief for the retail
industry
a lot of people saying that why do we
need to help fashion this
light industry i can tell you it is an
industry that is supporting america
when you're looking at gaap being the
number one
apparel purveyor to americans that's
supporting america when you look at the
number of employees that we are
employing that is not a light industry
it is not frivolous
it is incredibly important to our
economy
and it cannot be left behind so i read
that story and i thought okay this is
very interesting but i want to know
what's happening with the business and
then i reached out and i said hey i
would love to chat with
you about what's going on how is the
business doing and then how is tory
burch doing as a designer
and as an entrepreneur who's leading
this business and i think
what became clear with the story also
was that
you have to be very agile and you have
to
be able to pivot at a very tough time
and you know that has
emotional implications and that also has
a lot of business implications so
our conversations in the past month or
so
have been about keeping something you
love so much alive
at a time when staying alive is harder
than any other time
[Music]
the fashion industry relies on global
systems of manufacturing a disruption
like covet 19 can be disastrous for
every supplier involved
you have a cardigan and the button comes
from italy
and then because of covid italy is shut
down so you don't have a button
what happens to that cardigan you either
turn that cardigan into something else
if you can
or if you can't then you just scrap it
and you have to design something new
and i think the fact that she was able
to do that she was
able to design and they were able to
make certain business decisions
it was very fascinating to me i know
that they moved
production from asia to
brazil because south america shut down
later but it wasn't just manufacturing
that took a hit
the retail arm of tory burch faced a
dire situation as well
at one point almost all of
her stores were shut down maybe they
were not all shut down at the same time
but at one point she had to shut down
almost all of them they were thinking
about
opening uh 20 stores just in china
and you know plans are changing they've
had to improvise
shifting focus from physical stores to
e-commerce infrastructure and online
campaigns
beginning in china the middle east and
japan
tory burch started selling items on
tamale alibaba's retail site
and optimized all sites for mobile while
incorporating artificial intelligence to
generate personalized product
recommendations
birch also introduced virtual styling
which enables customers to make private
video appointments to see different
items in the store
according to a mckinsey report
industry-wide sales profits declined 93
in 2020 as consumers continue to stay
home and wear comfortable casual
clothing
there's definitely been a move towards
casual wear
the thing that tory burch herself
is focused on is they have tori sport
which is their
casual wear arm and they have been given
more exposure to their loungewear
collection
but at the same time she's saying people
will
always want to dress up and she's still
focused mostly on that and
what she and her husband are
specifically
focusing on is having iconic pieces
and i was talking to an analyst at
mckinsey who told me you know
the brands that are in luxury that are
going to survive the covet storm
are the ones that have iconic products
so it's just kind of like establishing
yourself as one of those brands and just
you know
having the tory birch bag be the thing
having the toy bird sandals be the thing
and then
you know the idea is that you're so good
that people will buy your stuff no
matter what
i think that's an optimistic way of
looking at things because
people are just not spending money how
do you make people
spend money and we're at a point where
we still don't know
obviously their private company they're
not telling us what sales are like but
they're telling us that the revenues
will be down by 20
this year and it could be more
they said you know if there's a second
wave we're ready for what comes you know
we know how to shut our stores we know
how to pivot to more e-commerce and
things like that
but at the same time there's still so
many unknowns and
the consumer psyche is still you know
more cautious
discretionary spending is down by a lot
almost 30 percent of luxury sales in
north
america and europe were done by
chinese travelers people are not
traveling
you know you can be as optimistic and
you can pivot as much as you like
but at the same time the pandemic will
always be an issue as long as it lasts
you